if you had had proper management as a
kid I would imagine you'd have a lot
more money right saved right your
affairs would have been handled
differently a planning would have been
involved I would not have done Teen Wolf
- did you dad tell you to do two more -
dad dad was very encouraging dad as a
producer on that film I'm not saying he
had ulterior motives career was going so
well your trajectory could have been
leading man a list [ __ ] movies I
would say though in his defense that he
he was he was the biggest advocate for
the high quality and the the very very
tasteful and my team all too well
because the the strategy was well let's
go do a quote studio movie get some
box-office relevance and then diversify
that into something tasteful the team
will to kill your acting career ah well
that's probably I mean if you were to
look back it probably will it probably
didn't help but I [ __ ] up business
it's like well you're probably fine and
Teen Wolf - it's just not the greatest
script there's so many things that made
that [ __ ] but you know probably be
included here you this kid you're on the
top of the world you're in all these
shows and suddenly I guess you're going
out on auditions right yeah that's the
kid from home that's an old ride right
so you start going out and now of a
sudden you're auditioning and it's not
like you're moving from one project to
the next right well yeah and I had sort
I had bought the attitude I clearly
needed to have been renting so I went
out there and and was very humbled and
it was you in a panic
yeah absolutely because you're like
what's my future well what what's what's
my what's my self-esteem what's what's
my ego you know you go into these
auditions and you want to kind of
posture like I'm the guy and they're
sort of make you wait in the lobby for
20 minutes and there's a guy who's never
acted yeah there's a big big adjustment
for someone who's who was naive about
the ups and the downs of the business
but truly if Arrested Development had
not come along who was the genius
responsible for putting you in Arrested
Development
my agent that I had actually just
stopped working with called me a couple
of months after that and said hey
there's this there's this I know you're
with that other agency now but I just I
haven't seen your name on the list for
this show that's that their audition
horn sounds like it'd be great for you
her name's leave real stain and she said
you should go in and definitely get seen
busily now your agent I mean I would
think so
no seriously why is Lee Lee had the saw
in you because I understand how
Hollywood views people ah that kid he
was he kid actor [ __ ] him he's old news
Jane Wall drinks blah blah blah screw
him
someone takes a chance and says hey
let's put him in so maybe it's time to
bring him back mature wits the the
runner of that show the the boss the
audition yeah yeah yeah and we would
like I'm not gonna get this oh yes I did
not think I was gonna get it because on
the on the cover of the script it's it
warned all the actors that were coming
in to audition this is not a show with
frills you will not have makeup you will
there is no lighting there's no marks on
the floor the dressing rooms are going
to be tiny it's it's shot like sort of
like cops right like documentaries so if
you want to be pampered do not audition
for the show so it seemed like not only
was it a no-frills thing but it was not
to bore you but television was moving
from like multi camera like sitcom stuff
into single camera which was kind of
cooler and hipper right and I had all
that multi camera baggage I was you know
cheesy right so I thought well they're
not gonna want my baggage on their cool
show so I was lucky to even get in to
begin with well you must have given some
hell of an audition right III guessed
right that that day as far as what they
want to see from the character and so
Arrested Development becomes sort of the
darling of Hollywood a lot of people in
Hollywood love that claim and it turns
everything around right because no one
else in the country was watching it but
the people in LA were why did you stop
drinking and having a good time we did
was it because you met your wife and she
said [ __ ] you you've got to get your
[ __ ] together I'm leaving yeah I was
already dialing it down a bit and
wanting to sort of I had caught up and I
wanted to now be an adult and and all
that crap so were us she said you ever
considered getting out of Hollywood oh
yeah yeah I fantasized about liquidating
what little I did have literally put the
cash in a duffle bag go down to the to
the Bradley terminal at LAX look up on
the ticker board pick a city anywhere in
the world and just unplug from here and
go plug it and just start over
do you think he would have done what
with the fantasy eye it's a dumb ass
soft fantasy but I was like gonna go to
some countryside coffee shop and Italy
or France learn the language and like
you know serve you know become a waiter
yeah really just be one of those guys
and become 450 pounds sounds great
well at least I wouldn't be exposed to
you know Entertainment Tonight every
night me not being on it or looking at
the trades and just that's painful right
when you see other people that were
industry towns when you see other people
that are we're sort of your peers all of
a sudden succeeding and you're having a
tough time there's got that's got to be
the worst pressure in the goddamn world
well yeah I mean that's one of the great
things about New York City is that
there's so many different trades here in
so many different areas to sort of have
influence and affluence and if you're
not I'm not on the top of the mountain
in the entertainment industry out in Los
Angeles it's tough to be socially
relevant during that period of time did
where their movies you went out on I
mean I'm talking about successful movies
that we would know where you got
rejected that you knew you would have
been it would have revived your career
yeah there have been some that I almost
said no to that I'm glad I did not say
no it's like what like why did you want
me to say no to Juno yes
why did you be why because when I read
that script I was in a weird mood and it
said no and we had just had a child and
I was I said no and then they then they
went to another actor and they got about
two weeks away from actually shooting
and that actor sent a text message to
Jason Reitman
simply saying I'm out Wow Jennifer
Garner actually said go back to Jason
and see if he'll reconsider because you
had realized that this could be a good
project well no I hadn't yet but she was
she wanted me to play the part and we
had done the kingdom together and we had
a really good time on that and so I
reread the script and what what what
sealed the deal for me is that I'm not
proud of this but my daughter was
colicky and she's screaming her [ __ ]
ass off driving and bananas I called my
manager I said where does it shoot he
said Vancouver I said how long he said
three weeks I said